after helping to feed Qatar for decades
this mill on doha's Waterfront will be
given a new role by replacing flour with
art
these towering silos are 35 meters tall
and 8.5 meters wide now the relationship
between artists curators and Industrial
spaces like this isn't new however what
Qatar Museum aims to do is to create a
gallery while keeping the industrial
Integrity intact
we wanted to keep as much of the
existing structures as possible but
there's also history there's memory the
bread for Doha comes from here the
project is expansive covering more than
80 000 square meters
is this a big building or a small City
because when measuring the site compared
to other institutions this is several
times the Venice biennale or the Tate
so the answer is both in the nearby
galleries
tells us the entire Waterfront area will
be transformed into a cultural Hub Qatar
is being ambitious and we're trying to
show International art Collections and
Regional art collections on the Corniche
and for them if they do come back in
2030 are able to see the realization of
these of these dreams and these plans
that we have as a country
foreign
cultural plans don't stop there they
Gallery called Tales of a connected
World gives a peek into the design of
the new Museum in the brand new city of
Lucille by prick surprise winning
Architects Herzog and demuron
inside each room is defined by color
soundscapes and looks at the influence
of Middle Eastern and Islamic Art In The
Wider world
we try to jump from a point of view
which is not the usual point of view of
museums because museums tend to be very
Colonial or poster onion it was very
important to bring in music to bring in
actually we're going to work on
workshops to be able to bring food and
perfume also with big plans that
transform its waterfronts into cultural
hubs kata's goal is to extend its impact
far beyond the FIFA World Cup
law about manly Al Jazeera Doha